we have a voicemail number which I
invite you to call any time of day if
it's 3:20 in the morning and you decide
you want to leave me 14 voicemails as
somebody did last night go ahead and do
it just you know if they're three
minutes long each don't expect them to
make it onto the show here is a
voicemail about the caller's that we get
on the show it's not particularly
charitable to the caller's take a listen
hi David
this is Peter from China look I don't
have a bone to pick with you today
I just want to praise you for your
amazing patience some of those callers
you get to your show complete morons and
you you slip it out and you show amazing
patience with with them when if it was
me I would have hung up on them a long
time ago so good on you good I knew
you've got amazing patience keep up the
good work and let me show ya well listen
uh the the patience and attention span
Jean runs in the Packman family and I I
do think that that is maybe part of why
I am able to entertain not only a 14
consecutive three minute voicemails
sometimes on the voicemail line but also
sometimes callers whose thesis statement
is not particularly well formed and they
are sort of working through it with me I
guess I'm trying to be polite here but
yes we welcome all sorts of different
callers on the program I don't care
about your gender I don't care about
your religion I don't care about your
sexual orientation country of origin
country of residency political
orientation IQ we it just everybody's
allowed to call in and we will be
respectful and polite to everybody until
such time that they are not respectful
to me and that's when I start to get a
little bit upset we've got a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
New York immediately having second
thoughts just days after ending cash
bail it's weird what's going on there
we're also going to talk about a lawsuit
from a transgender teen over a birth
certificate the right is having a field
day with a story and we will also talk
about face book banning deep fake videos
which is funny because
if the videos are good enough that you
can't tell that it's a deep fake
how can you ban it because you don't
know that that's what it is anyway we'll
talk about that in the future of deep
fake technology on today's bonus show in
mere moments how to access the bonus
show two ways number one become a member
at join pakman.com that will give you
instant access option to become a patron
for at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will speak to you then or otherwise on
tomorrow's program